*Générique* A travers les époques les dangers, une grande aventure les appelle
C'est, c'est, c'est l'Épopée Temporelle * Fin du générique*
Narrateur : Nous sommes sur le Titanic. Enfin quand je dis "nous" je parle pas de "vous" et de "moi"
Je parle d'Iris, Elliott le Lapin, Thomas et Thomas. Et oui il y a deux Thomas,
celui qu'on connaît et Thomas qui vient d'un futur indescriptible.
Ils doivent empêcher un mystérieux personnage de modifier le temps... Et j'ai une petite théorie de qui ça peut être.... On vous le dit à la fin !
Lapin : Vite trouvez ce type qui veut modifier le temps
Iris : Et avant que le Titanic coule...
si possible ! (Thomas) Attendez... mais on est dans un
un film ?! (Thomas du futur) On va croiser Jack et
rose ?... (Iris) Pff Oh lala...
Il est pas beaucoup plus intelligent dans le futur hein...
Non non... Jack et Rose il existe pas fait par contre le Titanic il a vraiment...  (Speaker) Bonjour à tous, je suis Joël votre connaisseur de bord, nous avons une annonce à vous faire...
Sur la brochure du voyage, nous vous avions promis un passage au milieu des icebergs...
Malheureusement nous allons devoir annuler !...
Effectivement,  une personne très bien attentionnée a prévenu notre Capitaine de Navire des risques de cette magnifique ballade milieu des icebergs
se basant sur une très très bonne documentation, notamment un vidéogramme documentaire de trois heures avec une chanson qui reste dans la tête...
chantonne faux "Titanic"
Bref ! Excusez-moi pour ce changement de dernière minute mais la sécurité c'est important ! Surtout quand on manque de bateaux de sauvetage...
Bon voyage à tous !
Thomas du futur : C'est très agréable de la part de cette personne.
Iris : Mais le voilà c'est lui ! Le méchant veut empêcher le Titanic de couler...  (Lapin) : c'est ça il est en train de modifier le temps.
Je le sens.. et... et je crois que je me...
désintègre.... ahahhhhhhaaa !!!!
Thomas : Mais regardez, il est en train de disparaître comme dans "Retour vers le Futur" (Lapin) Malheureusement, c'est beaucoup plus douloureux que ça !
aheugurha hi....
Je vais me recroqueviller sur moi-même...
et je... bordel de...
cul ! Ohaahhhhhhh ça fait
maaaaaaaallll !!!! Haaaaaaaaa !.....
Iris : Oohh petit lapin !!!  (Elliott) : Le petit lapin a disparu (Iris) : Merde, ça veut dire que le temps est modifié !
Thomas du futur : Attendez... On est coincé ici ?....
Iris : Non non non ! Il va réapparaître
mais pour ça, on doit remettre le temps comme il l'était et et empêcher le méchant de sauver le Titanic. (Thomas) : Mais y'a rien de méchant à
sauver le Titanic ! (Elliott) : Papa a été clair, il faut laisser le temps intact si le - Titanic -
ne coule pas, ça va créer d'importants changements qui vont nous mener à l'apocalypse... (Iris) :  Non mais arrête de l'appeler papa heuu...
c'est gênant ! (Elliott) Il m'a conçu et je suis - un humain - je suis comme son fils ! (Iris) : Pourquoi vouloir empêcher le Titanic de couler ?...
Aargh je comprends rien ! (Thomas du futur) : Vous voulez qu'on coule le Titanic ? (Thomas) Mais t'inquiète pas, Jack et Rose n'existent pas on est dans un film...
Les gens vont pas vraiment mourir... (Iris) :  Ouai
voilà, on va dire ça... Y faut refaire la fin du film. Mais comment faire exactement le même trou
sans iceberg ? (Elliott) : Un trou ne suffira pas !  L'iceberg avait traversé plusieurs niveaux pour faire sombrer le bateau. (Iris) : T'as raison Elliott
comment faire plusieurs trous à plusieurs niveaux ? (Thomas) : On peut utiliser mon laser ! (Iris) : C'est juste de la lumière...
Thomas : Bah non, sinon on appellerai ça " une lumière" et pas un "laser"... (Tom du futur) : Pendant que vous parliez,
j'ai fabriqué des bombes avec du savon et différents produits ménagers. (Iris) : Super ! (Thomas) : Et bah moi pendant que vous parliez j'ai fait
semblant de comprendre la situation.... (Iris) :  Mais Thomas,  comment tu sais fabriquer des bombes ? (Tom du futur) : Dans mon époque si tu sais fabriquer une bombe, t'es
un homme mort ! (Iris) : Ah.. ça fait envie... (Elliott) : Voici un plan en 3D holographique de l'impact de l'iceberg sur le :  - Titanic -
Vous voyez l'entaille ? (Iris) :  Ouais, l'entaille traverse la coque. (Thomas) : Du hentaï ? Ou ça du Hentaï ? (Elliott) : Voilà où poser les bombes pour recréer l'incident. (Thomas) : J'vois
pas d'tentacules ! (Iris) : Bon voilà le plan !  On va se diviser en trois groupes.  Elliott, tu vas dans la salle des machines,
les "Thomas", vous allez en seconde classe, moi je vais en première classe.  On place les explosifs,
on se retrouve sur le pont, on fait tout péter en même temps et... (Thomas) :
ON REFAIT LE FILM
TITANIC YESSSSSS !!! (Tom du futur) : Enfin enfin quelque chose d'amusant dans ma vie de souffrance . (Iris) : Oui oui... Mais
Elliott, on doit vraiment tuer des gens innocents ? (Elliott) : Peu importe, ils sont déjà décédés dans notre époque. (Iris) : Oui mais quand même...
Il suffirait de rien faire et des tas de gens survivraient. (Elliott) : Je te rappelle que c'est le plan d'un méchant. Il y a peut-être un tueur d'enfants
parmi ceux qui sont morts sur le Titanic... (Thomas) : Je comprends rien vos dilemmes... (Elliott) : Si on ne fait pas couler le : - Titanic -
le temps sera modifié, le lapin ne viendra plus nous chercher, et on restera coincé en :
1912 !! Pour toujours... (Iris) :  Oui tu as raison...
Iris : Bon, c'est parti pour l'opération...
bah Titanic !
Elliott : Quelle salle horrible ! Que des machines sans âmes...
Voilà, cet emplacement semble parfait pour l'explosif... (Mécanicien) Hey, vous faites quoi ici ? Cet endroit est réservé aux mécaniciens hein !
Elliott : Bonjour cher ami, je suis un : - humain - attribué à la profession de mécanicien
tout comme vous. (Mécano) Et alors ?  Bah je vous ai jamais vu moi ! (Elliott) : Vos yeux sont peut-être défaillants, je travaille ici depuis :
un million deux cent neufs mille six cents secondes soit : - deux semaines - (Mécano) : Ah excusez et moi mon brave, en ce moment je suis plus très attentif...
Ce métier me rend fou... Ma femme ne le reconnaît plus hein... Elle dit que je deviens un robot sans émotions.
Elliott : Hin hin hin
les femmes, je vous jure, avec leurs émotions sinusoïdales... On ne peut pas vivre avec mais on ne peut pas vivre sans...
c'est ce que je pense en tant : - qu'humain -  de sexe : - masculin - du début du : - vingtième siècle - (Mécano) : Ouah elle a p'tète raison, à force de rester avec des machines....
J'en viens p'tète une... J'manque de contact avec le reste du monde, ça c'est un fait évident... (Elliott) :  C'est une histoire très divertissante, qu'est-ce que je rigole !
HIN HIN HIN...
J'ai du travail maintenant. Je dois : - surveiller la pression d'une turbine alternative qui alimente les deux hélices latérales à trois pales... Selon Wikipedia !
Au revoir ! (Mécano) : Ah bah désolé collègue de vous avoir embêté avec mes histoires...
Elliot : Je pars en sifflotant...
Mécano : Personne ne comprend... Ne suis-je qu'une machine de plus dans ce monde qui n'a plus de sens ?...
Sanglots....
Lapin : Mais qu'est ce que ça pue ici...
Tom du futur : Tais-toi, quelqu'un arrive...
Lapin : Bienvenue Messieurs. (Passager) : Vous aussi, vous avez mis toutes vos économies dans ce voyage pour tenter une nouvelle vie sur le continent américain ?
Thomas : Ouais, ouais c'est ça ouais ! (Passager) : Venez vous amuser avec nous, on n'a plus d'argent,
ici la nourriture n'est pas bonne et la plupart d'entre nous tombent malades
- toux -
Mais on a des rêves plein la tête et on sait que l'arrivée sera la chance qu'on mérite ! (Toux) (Thomas) :  T'entends ça ?
il a pas vu la fin du film ! Plouf, tout le monde dans l'eau !
Tom du futur : Thomas du passé, je vais faire diversion.
Grâce à ton corps frêle, tu te frayes un passage au milieu de la foule pour rejoindre la paroisse du fond.
Places y la bombe et fais-moi un signe discret quand c'est bon... (Thomas) : Ca marche ! On forme tellement une équipe de choc...
Top là ! (claque dans la main) AÏÏÏEEE !
Pffff, agghh.. bon euuh...
J'y vais, j'y vais... (Tom du futur) : Aah ah, qu'est ce qu'on s'amuse ici ! Regardez mes muscles !
Ca vous plait les filles ?
Une fille : Oh l'homme, qu'est qu'il est fort...
Et les messieurs également...
Alors ? (un homme) : ouais, ouais...
Thomas : Ah excusez moi, pardon, voilà, désolé, désolé hein ! Hop, (bébé qui pleure) pardon petit bébé
ah désolé monsieur...
euh.. pardon madame... Ah argh hé..
Voilà, alors, je mets la bombe juste là.... C'est bon, j'ai placé
la BOMBE !!! (La foule) Hein ?!!....
beuheu heueueueuu...
...bastic say me fantastic, touch me on me butt she say I'm Mr. Ro... mantic
Mr Bombastic, call me fantastic,
touch me on me butt
she say I'm romantic
Mr Bombastic yeahhhh
Tom du futur : On l'a échappé belle, heureusement qu'on a un sacré beau brin de voix !
Thomas : J'avais appris cette musique pour la kermesse
de l'école ! (Tom du futur) : Je sais
Je veux plus qu'on en parle ok ? (Thomas) : J'espère qu'Iris en saura aussi bien
que nous !
Iris ! C'est dingue c'que les riches peuvent faire de leur argent... Et dire que y'a des gens qui ont plus un sou juste sous mes pieds...
Une passagère : Mademoiselle !
Simplement pour vous dire que votre robe est ravissante. (Iris) : merci excusez moi, mais je suis attendue ! (Passagère) :  Je me présente
Julia Florence Chefowling, mon, mari est à la tête de la WSL Company. Et vous ? Avec qui ai-je l'honneur de discuter ?...
Iris : Heu...
Iris !  (Julia) Hum hum.... Et votre nom de famille ? Etes-vous sûre de ne pas vous être trompée
d'étage ?
Sécurité ! Je crois qu'une pauvre s'est retrouvée... (Iris) : Vianney de Préto ! Iris
Vianney de Preto. Mon mari dirige la PNL Company. (Julia) :  Ouh lala, excusez-moi vraiment, je suis confuse... J'ai cru un instant que vous n'étiez
pas heuu...
comme... (Iris) :  Vous voulez dire.. Riche ? (Bouchon de champagne qui saute et foule qui crie) CHAMPAGNE !!!
Julia) : Hahaha oui,
Voilà !  Et qui rejoignez-vous ? Je peux vous aider à retrouver cette personne ?
(Iris) : C'est heuu, c'est heuu...
Maître Gims de La Vega ! (Julia) : Je ne connais pas cet avocat...
Ouh lala ! Souhaitez-vous un macaron à la framboise
ou encore un éclair à la pistache ? (Iris) : Ecoutez, je vais être franche, je ne suis pas très à l'aise avec toute ces abondances...
Ne trouvez vous pas que vos privilèges sont la source des...
(mange un éclair et parle la bouche pleine) humm humm c'est "cro" bon !
Julia : Hum, évidemment, notre chef pâtissier à travailler dans les endroits les plus prestigieux. (Iris en mâchant) : Oh
ça défonce, c'est une tuerie !!!
Qu'est-ce qu'on disait ?... (Julia) : Humm, vous parliez du fait que nous soyons... riches ! (POP) !
La foule : CHAMPAGNE !!!
Iris : Ah mai non non mais oubliez hein... Vous pouvez me rendre un service ? Mais bien sûr, entres riches...
POOP ! CHAMPAGNE !!!
Voici un paquet, posez-le contre la paroi là-bas. (Julia) : Ouhh c'est lourd c'est lourd et ça fait tic-tac !
Oh oh je vois. Une montre de luxe que vous allez offrir à Maître Gims de La Vega ? Non ne me dites rien.. Comptez sur moi...
Iris : Oui c'est ça ! Merci ma beauté. Je dois filer. Je vous reprends juste quelques éclairs....
(Iris la bouche pleine) : Ohoh oh
délicieux franchement !
Par contre, ça doit être riche en sucre hein...
Foule qui rit : CHAMPAGNE !!!
Iris : C'est bon ? Les explosifs sont en  place ? (Elliott) : Parfaitement...
J'ai rempli ma tâche.
Iris : Qu'est ce que j'entends ? C'est Shaggy ? (Thomas) : C'est assez long à expliquer... (Tom du futur) : Vas-y Riggs, appuie le détonateur. (Elliott) : Fais couler le bateau.
Iris : Oui oui oui, attendez attendez, on est sur le bateau, il va couler
mais et nous ?! (Elliott) : Le lapin vient nous récupérer. (Iris) : Mouais mais s'il  revient pas ?... (Elliott) : Je ne sais pas Iris, c'est toi qui nous à dit qu'il reviendrait
si on rétablissait le temps. (Iris) : Baah oui, mais j'ai j'ai dit ça comme ça heuu... (Thomas) : J'en ai marre d'attendre... Je veux voir la fin du film !
J'adore la chanson du générique. DONNE MOI CA !!!
(Thomas déclenche l'explosion) BIP BIP !
(plusieurs explosions)
(La foule crie et panique)
Thomas : Ouaaah ! Ho ho ho !
Speaker : Re Bonjour, toujours Joël
Nous avons un petit problème, mais restez calme, pas de panique...
A l'intention des pauvres, restez dans vos chambres hein, tout va bien ! Merci de boucher vos oreilles... C'est bon ?
Bon maintenant les riches... POP CHAMPAGNE !
Des canots de sauvetage sont à votre disposition...
ALORS BONNE JOURNEE ! LAISSEZ-MOI UNE PLACE !!!!
LAISSEZ-MOI UNE PLAAAACEEE !!!!!
Lapin : On dirait que la mission est réussie ! (Iris) : Aahhh il est apparu
exactement comme je l'avais annoncé. (Lapin) : vous avez attrapé le méchant ? (Iris) : Non, on n'a pas eu le temps de l'approcher... (Thomas) : Quoi ? Y'a un méchant ?...
Lapin ! Le docteur Simon a capté une nouvelle modification dans le temps à Florence en 1503 ! Ce doit être lui... On y va ?!
Thomas : Excuses-moi mais on dit : chez Florence et pas
à Florence, tu dis pas : "je vais à le coiffeur"... (Elliott) : C'est en Italie... alors on dit chez Florence en Italie... (Thomas) : Bah alors on dit : "chez Florence en Italie"...
Iris : Bon on y va... (Tom du futur) : On va l'attraper...
Elliott : Retemporalisation dans... Ah non c'est vrai...
Lapin : Retemporalisation IMMEDIATE !!!
Narrateur : Alors voilà ma théorie ! Vous en faites ce que vous voulez !  Le mec qui modifie le temps c'est...
Adolf Hitler... Il est sorti de la faille, je sais pas comment mais il veut casser le temps parce qu'il a le "seum" !
Vous en pensez quoi ? Bah dites-moi dans les commentaires ! Moi, je les lis tous ! Contrairement à Cyprien... Hoah, il a pris la grosse tête !....
Cyprien : Merci d'avoir écouté et à la semaine prochaine pour le troisième épisode de l'EPOPEE TEMPORELLE